to be a good undercover cop you've got
to be a very convincing liar if you
can't lie don't apply you also need to
have an element of uh courage because a
lot of the time it's very
nerve-wracking and also equally as
important you have to be able to think
on your feet to be adaptable because so
much of what you do is business
negotiation I would always say
be the person that is as close to you as
you possibly can be
because yeah I was a South London kid so
I pretended to be a South London villain
because the easiest lies to tell are the
ones that are closest to the truth and I
used to tell all the youngsters coming
through that we trained to don't try and
be what you fundamentally are not